as Lieutenant Commander data on Star
Trek The Next Generation
brent Spiner saved the enterprise on
more than one occasion and allowed the
show to explore ethical questions about
just what it means to be an Android in a
world of humans despite being the least
human of the caste data quickly became a
fan favorite character all the way
through the series 1994 finale and for
subsequent films but what happened to
Spiner after Star Trek ended
Independence Day in 1996
Spiner made an appearance in the smash
science-fiction hits Independence Day
though many fans may not have recognized
him after seeing him as the stoic data
for so long you can spot spider in the
path of dr. brackish oathean the young
Kem's and enthusiastic director of area
51 who joins a surgical team during an
autopsy on one of the aliens
although Oken appears to meet a messy
end Spina returned to reprise his role
in the 2016 sequel introducing Dorothy
Dandridge in 1999 Spiner landed a
co-starring role alongside Halle Berry
in the HBO production introducing a
Dorothy Dandridge a biopic focusing on
the life of a singer dancer and actress
who battled against pervasive racial
discrimination a during her incredible
career spyler appears as Elle Mills
Dandridge his friend and manager
throughout the rise and fall of her to
brief career Mills stood by her side
until the end the day he found a body
after she passed away at age 42 returned
to Star Trek even though data storyline
was wrapped up during the course of 2002
Star Trek nemesis the franchise wasn't
completely done with Spiner well the
door was left open for him to
potentially return as an identical
Android finer felt had gotten too old to
play the ageless robot but in 2004 he
appeared on Star Trek enterprises Eric
soon
a criminal geneticist and ancestor of
datas creator dr. Noonien Soong who was
also played by Spiner
by the end of soon's Ark in the prequel
series the foundations are laid for the
creation of data Spina on film although
many of its films have been relatively
minor Spiner has had some scene-stealing
moments including his appearance in the
1996 John Travolta fantasy drama
phenomenon of an FBI doctor in 2002
Spiner appeared as bad guy Devlin Bowman
and the notorious Eeyore for Dana Carvey
comedy the master of the skies the
entire movie was a vehicle to showcase
Carvey's impressive mimicry skills but
it didn't work the master of the skies
was a commercial and critical flop and
playing a ridiculously flatulent villain
didn't do Spiner any favours is she dead
Spiner also appeared in the Jack Lemmon
and Walter Matthau comedy al tusi
and made a brief appearance in the 2004
Howard Hughes biopic The Aviator in 2006
Spina returned to the big screen for
another comedy the teen focused material
girls starring Hilary and Haylie Duff
playing the nefarious co-founder of a
cosmetics company although it fared
slightly better with critics and the
master of disguise that also has been
saying much the film was nominated for
multiple Razzies and was one of the
worst reviewed films of the 2000s
threshold in 2005 finest art along with
Peter Dinklage and carla Gugino in a CBS
sci-fi series threshold the trio forms
the core of a secret u.s. governmental
think-tank tasked with humanities first
extraterrestrial contact where the
Spiner playing dr. Nigel Fenway a NASA
microbiologist the top-secret red team
is in charge of researching and
containing an incident on an American
naval vessel where several crew members
die horribly after encountering a UFO
although it was cancelled after only one
season threshold is a must watch for
brent Spiner Femmes voice acting because
Spiner has such a rich theatre
background it probably shouldn't be
surprising that he's done plenty of
voiceover work over the years in the
1999 movie South Park bigger Longer &
uncut he provides the voice of talk-show
host Conan O'Brien he's also taken voice
roles on several TV shows including the
role of the Joker on Young Justice
ladies and gentlemen we interrupt your
regularly scheduled mayhem to break
you'll see his credits also include
purple man in the Avengers earth the
mightiest heroes The Simpsons Star Wars
rebels and Family Guy I want some
McNuggets we'll get to you Brent if
you're a fan of the video game early
dangerous now you can get spiders voice
in your spaceship he provided a voice
pack for Vega in 2016 fresh hell in 2011
Spiner co-created and started his own
web series fresh hell the show depicts a
fictionalized version of Spiner
trying to rebuild his career after
losing everything spine is unexpected
comedic talents shine and the episodes
are short and funny fans who haven't
seen it yet should definitely give our
watch spine has also made plenty of
guest appearances as himself on TV
including the friend spin-off Joey and
the Big Bang Theory where he reunites
with his next generation co-star Wil
Wheaton at a birthday party
Spiner has also appeared as himself on
the guild as one of many other shows
warehouse 13
finer made his return to science fiction
in several episodes of the sci-fi series
warehouse 13 during the show's fourth
season over a six episode arc Spiner
appears with brother Adrian a vatican
agent and a member of the Brotherhood of
the Black Diamond upon returning to
science-fiction Spiner told sci-fi I'm
not like really zeroed in focused on
sci-fi but if it's good sci-fi I like it
I like westerns too I like comedy I was
much more of a Lucy kind of guide and I
was a Star Trek kind of guy but fate is
taking me in this direction outcast
since 2016 - biggest project has been
the Cinemax horror series outcast in
which he plays Sydney the mysterious
preacher involved in a tale of demonic
possession in a small West Virginia town
for fans who love spiders workers data
seeing him in such a dark role might be
disturbing at first but it showcases the
menacing side of his acting one we
haven't really seen since data's brother
law was deactivated for good and the
playing at gassy villain doesn't count
[Laughter]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]